june's jobs report shows employers added
850 000 jobs last month which is up from
583
000 in may and may's unemployment rate
of 5.8
ticked up to 5.9 for june
last month's jobs gain leaves us still
millions
of drops short of where we were right
before the pandemic hit
at the same time the number of job
openings has grown really quickly
in recent months and the number of
unemployed people
nearly matches the number of job
openings which
raises the question why aren't those
unemployed people
filling those job openings right now a
lot of people
are vaccinated they're going out again
they're traveling
eating at restaurants and so businesses
need to hire to meet that demand
however a lot of unemployed people or
people without work
are not even looking for a job right now
we've seen that the number of job
openings are growing
in hospitality recreation and food
service industries but many workers who
filled these jobs
could still be reluctant or unable to
return to these types of jobs
some have health concerns still about
the coronavirus
in other cases you have parents who have
to stay at home
with their kids because schools and day
cares are still at least partially shut
down
and then others might be holding out
looking for work because of expanded
unemployment benefits
federal reserve chairman jerome powell
says that there's another reason
the very quick job gains of the early
recovery
essentially involved going back to your
old job that's that's not so much what's
happening now now it's actually finding
new jobs and
that's a that's a matching function that
that is more labor-intensive and
time-consuming and there may be a bit of
a speed limit on that
employers now have to basically rebuild
their workforces from scratch
so their employees that they laid off
last summer they might have moved to a
different city for instance
and now that employer has to find
people who are nearby june's numbers
show that the percentage of americans
working or
actively looking for work held steady at
61.6
in june which tells us that there are
still a lot of americans who have yet to
return to the job market
labor force participation fell really
sharply at the beginning of the pandemic
and has had a very slow recovery in some
cases people are just
discouraged their industries might not
be coming back very quickly and so
they're not looking for jobs right now
average hourly earnings grew really
swiftly last month
and this is a sign that employers are
ramping up
wages as they have to attract workers in
this really competitive market
and there could be implications for
inflation because
if companies have to increase wages they
also might have to
pass along price increases to customers
they're doing things like offering
bonuses and pay raises
and this puts workers in a really strong
position they have a lot of bargaining
power and we expect this to continue for
the next
at least few months